he's not set foot in washington since
january last year donald trump had left
the place he calls the swamp insisting
he'd won the election he lost now nearly
18 months on he's back
we gather today on the verge of a
historic midterm election
the american people are poised to reject
the failed reign of joe biden nancy
pelosi chuck schumer and the radical
left in a
momentous landslide this is an
incredible opportunity
the former president has been in
constant campaign mode since he left
office dismissed as background noise by
many but a leader still for his
followers
the evidence from the inquiry into the
capital riots has been genuinely
revealing i don't want to say the
elections are but i just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
but if there was a view that this from
his followers and the two impeachments
would disqualify trump was it in fact
just act one
we now know the extent of donald trump's
involvement in those riots rallying the
mob choosing not to tell them to stand
down ignoring the advice from his own
people even his own family insisting as
he still does that he won the election
it certainly says something about where
america is right now that mr trump can
feel comfortable in being poised to run
again
the midterms are just a few months away
joe biden is deeply unpopular an aging
disappointment for so many who chose him
and that's an opportunity for
republicans weighing up a second act of
the trump show or is there another
candidate who can develop trumpism
without trump
in the same town on the same day his
one-time wingman vice president pence
now eyeing his own run aware that he
needs trump's base
i don't know that the president and i
differ on issues
but we may differ on focus
the facts are that donald trump was the
loser last time around but if he drops
his obsession with that then it's
possible his party will rally round him
for another shot at the white house mark
stone sky news in washington